discipline I had to get into was how I
was paying myself first even when I had
no money and would have all these bill
collectors calling me I use them as
inspiration when the government's
hounding you bill collectors calling us
I've been broke so I can you understand
what it feels like to be broke when
those guys are calling you instead of
you know shrinking and going into the
shell I use it as motivation to go out
and make more money
I used my bill collectors as motivation
and that's why I paid myself first I was
bought assets I buy a house or I'd put
money in the bank we were our biggest
asset we're also a biggest liability the
common wisdom the old intelligence idea
is to diversify and what I believe in
this is something else is increase your
financial IQ you financial like
intelligence and instead focus and what
focus stands for is this focuses follow
one course till you're successful that's
what I did in 1973 I signed up for my
first real estate investment course and
I just did it and did it and did it I
bought this one little $18,000 place and
I did it again and I did it again and I
did it again until the point where I
understood it then I went into becoming
an entrepreneur and I did it and I did
it and did it I'm still learning and I'm
still learning about real estate if
you're going to be successful as it
investor diversification is good for the
average investor that's what you want to
be have a good life what I'd rather do
is be able to know the good ones from
the bad ones the good investments for
the bad investments the good advisers
from the bad advisers and what's good
for me and what's not good for you
that's why I really think instead of
diversification the new rules of money
say follow one course until you're
successful and then keep doing it
because once you find that way of being
successful you can do it again and again
and again you just watched two amazing
clips from Robert Kiyosaki take the next
three minutes to sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]